[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you guys just tapped into the group chat
live in the bleacher report app
presented by fanduel my name is cabbie
richards the best betting expert in the
business
is in the middle of the screen her name
is kelly stewart and from the gay barrio
always bringing immaculate vibes greg
ivory aka g
money welcome to you both tonight is a
major night on the calendar steph curry
luka doncic listen steph curry has been
rewriting the history books
this month this guy's hit 85
three-pointers the most
in the history of the sport in one
calendar month
steph curry is in full nba 2k mode
and um it's been great he's got 85
three-pointers
he's got two games left this month he
might hit a hundred we asked you
earlier on social today who will score
more points
wardell steph curry stephen curry i
should say
or luka doncic now it should be noted
that luka doncic
is questionable so the new question is
will steph curry score over 33 and a
half
points this evening against the dallas
mavs
on his home court at oracle where
g-money
has won some money um greg is it
possible that your audience
can be happy yes or have you been
through
i'm afraid he's not at or unfortunately
they're not in the town anymore they're
across the bay
at the chase center oh my bad you're
right you're right
it's okay i i we're here gabby me you
we are here we're a team and thank you
for picking me up you really are
you are really are the draymond green of
our crew uh
kelly is the steph curry and i'm klay
thompson i'm just super chill
anyway let's get to the question will
steph curry hit over
or score over 33.5 points g-money i need
you to tap in with your army
can they be impartial and give
uh and not be a homer like you
wow partha let me ask him that was me
and cavs you guys be impartially
drained on it just slandered him
it's okay it was it was mild slander it
was like just a little bit of seasoning
can we be impartial here guys and can
you guys let me know if
we're riding with steph curry to go over
33 and a half points uh
just think yes but uh kelly
what are you thinking do you have a way
to handicap
it of course there's a way to handicap
this greg but i am in like a glass case
of emotion here in this bubble because
steph curry 37 32 18 49
47 33 42 53 38
32 those are his last 10 games
two of the games he's went under this
total
this total is too high it should be 32
and a half
31 and a half and i would gladly say
give me the overall day
but i'm gonna tell you this right now i
cannot bet the under against steph curry
especially not against a mediocre
defensive three team
in the dallas mavericks because guess
what happened well we'll get to that
later on in the show but we know
the dallas mavics give up too many dang
threes and cost people five team parlays
the end i
like kelly stewart likes to stay likes
to say i don't want to step in front of
that train
we all know that steph curry has just
been amazing this month
it is two games against the mavericks
this season this guy is averaging
42 and a half points he's shooting 52
percent
from three-point range against the mavs
and according to cleaningtheglass.com
they are the 25th ranked defense now
even if steph doesn't really have a
going tonight he still shoots 92 percent
from the free-throw line and you know
that
he likes that you know he'll take it to
the hoop he'll get his teammates
involved but he'll get that contact
and he'll get those foul calls because
he is wardell steph curry
so i'm taking the over tonight over 33
and a half points i'm not sure how maybe
36 maybe 37
continuing his mvp campaign greg ivory
uh what say you sir will um will he be
doing all the scoring himself or will
he unlock steph curry playmaker mode and
get draymond get uber
get wiggins get jta involved in the in
the w
the potential w tonight against the
mavericks cabbie
steph is gonna step he's gonna do what
he's been doing the whole
year which is scoring points and getting
his teammates involved i'm not gonna
come at you guys with numbers i'm not
gonna come at you guys with statistics
kelly did cabbie did all you guys gotta
do go on youtube you guys probably do it
anyway
look up steph curry highlights for like
just go back a week ago
all you gotta do is go back a week and
he's been absolutely balling
it's been absolutely bald and the
highlights will tell you the story
uh to take the over here because he's
he's been he's been hot he's been hot
he's been scoring
like like himself these last what 10 10
15 games whatever it is so uh take the
over i'm rocking with the over
let me get into the comments because i
see a lot of over i see a lot of over
my guy martin levinson says way over
shout out to you martin you're walking
away with a hoodie
uh i got ben the goat ben the goat says
corey's i mean curry's dropping 45.
shout out to you ben the goat you are
walking away with a hoodie
uh i got i got one more for you kevin i
got one more
my guy husta muss he got the bay area
bay area mac dre
uh here we go mac dre gift going on
shouts out to the yay
yes sir uh i'm i'm i'm giving him a
hoodie for that shout out to him i guess
he's rocking with steph in the over so
it looks like
they're rocking with all of us you know
what g money i really miss those parking
lot chronicles
that uh javale mcgee and kevin durant
used to do remember that they post up in
the park yeah that jiff just reminded me
of that and javel mcgee was like
he was just so awesome but i missed that
anyway um
speaking of scorching hot that's where
that's where my brain takes me to
the three by two it's three by tuesday
this is the best bet in america
it continues to scorch uh we invented it
it's basically there's the question will
there be two three-pointers made
in the first two minutes of the game
last week we locked in
the philadelphia 76ers and the milwaukee
bucks and this
[Music]
thank you uncle drew you know that was
his only three-pointer of the game
but we appreciate it chris middleton had
he was four for seven
that cash so quickly the milwaukee bucks
went on to score
to hit 23 pointers in that game and blew
the doors off
of the sixers so tonight we have the
dallas mavericks and the golden state
warriors
to again the question will there be two
three-pointers made
in the first three minutes of the game
greg ivory
what say you cabbie yes we've been doing
this
since the beginning but people already
know i'm pretty sure they're already
yeses in the comments
uh i like that presentation
do i even gotta go ahead cubby no you
know i meant to i meant to throw it to
the uh our twitter poll
we did ask you guys earlier yes or no
the three by two caches tonight look at
that oh this might be the most
overwhelming response we've gotten
87 of you uh on twitter
say yes the three by two is gonna cash
but most of the audience is in the
comment section g money so i'll let you
tap
in with the army and see what they say
hey shout out to my guy
derose01gkmc you were walking away with
it
because he has yes he has yes before we
even he he's already he knows what's up
he knows what's up he knows we are
writing kathy do i even really have to
ask this question anymore i mean
now that i'm scrolling even the more all
i'm seeing is a bunch of
yeses like audience all right are we
riding a three by two just
continue to fill the comments up with a
lot of yeses give me gifts get creative
fill these comments up remember
porzingis is doubtful
and luca is questionable so that limits
some fire power on the other side of
the court cabbie it's worth noting 30
is on the court that's all that that's
worth noting
that's worth noting 30 is on the court
30's on the court so is two-way wigs
i think yeah two-way two-way wigs out
there two-way wigs uber
out there michael michael mulder has
been nice for you guys
oh yeah yeah yeah he's a key asset off
the bench i like
he's he's okay he's okay
we'll see he has he has that butter shot
off the bench definitely
can shoot the three uh so g-money um are
you you're
you're rocking yes or no tabby
i know okay yes you're rocking okay
kelly kells
where where are we at here are you on
the three by two of course
i'm on the three by two cabbie you're
the only one in this group chat that
ever says no you're the only naysayer
ever
someone in regards to the 3x2
listen i understand no porzingis scares
me
luca being questionable i do think he
will see the court
i've been scouring twitter trying to
find out i do think that there's an
overreaction to both of those guys
being out and i do think that greg has a
really good point when he says that
steph
is on the court because we know steph
could hit three
three-pointers within those first couple
of minutes
this is definitely but guys in the first
two games
the three by two did you hit it stop it
three by two did not hit
okay all right that's bad vibes cabbie
that
no that's those are factual vibes the
actual vibes there we go now we got a
new one oh
yeah okay listen
i love the fact that those are bad vibes
michael mulder
has been great for for golden state i
love dorian finney smith on the other
side of the court for the mavs
um maybe maybe the third time's the
charm
maybe it's those two guys that that that
get a certain that's all we need we just
need two three points
so reluctantly i will say yes the 3x2
caches tonight
what is what's your audience saying you
know steph gets cooking later in the
game my dude not right right from the
jump no
cabbie he has to he he has to my my b
keeps coming out
but he he has to get he lets one go
early he always does he lets one go
early one or two
he he does it all the time he has to you
know get acclimated to the to the game
to the arena wherever he is i know do
you have
do you have the appropriate vibes in the
comments the vibes that you want do they
are they
i need to see factual vibes gifts
and emojis because i'm just curious to
what that actually looks like i feel
like it's like the nerd
emoji and i don't know what else
i need this guy it's it's this guy it's
the oh it's a fax machine shut up
it's a fax machine emotional or a fax
and something else yes
that's what i feel like it is so that's
my guy kobe hartman
kobe hartman he he he got bad vibes
going here
shout out shout out to you shout out to
you and you're gonna get some better
vibes
we're gonna get some better vibes here
going i see a lot of uh
yeses cabbie see a whole bunch of you
guys mgo blue 16 shout out to you you're
walking away with a hoodie
uh let me see
uh ryan r-y-e-n
ray r-uh r-y-e-n i struggle with him on
thursday
i know exactly what you're talking about
that was a that was a weird yeah right
yeah yeah double up uh
golden golden gold
mf nugget gold mf nugget your walkway
hey the comments are moving i'm sorry i
had to like focus in the comments are
moving we're all rocking
they're all rocking with the yes cabbie
one thing we have to remind you guys is
check out br betting socials for the
link to the
odds boost from fanduel the 3x2 that's
the only way to get it
download the app and get involved three
by two so
um wardell stephen curry has been adding
to his legendary career this month
he's playing like aladdin's genie
granted him a wish
this guy has been amazing and the mvp
conversation
needs to include steph curry this is the
weird thing to money okay
so no this is the thing the mvp
conversation this season started with
luca dontich
and then lebron james was in the lead
and then joel embiid was in the lead
now nicole jokic is in the lead james
harden made an appearance
giannis is in the mix and now steph
curry in the past month
has shot his way into the it is so wide
open but the question remains now that
steph curry
has arrived in the mvp conversation
proper
for his third potential trophy how many
people in the comments section have
a steph curry mvp ticket
let us know g money where where are your
bay area supporters
where are your wardell supporters uh
they should be in the comments uh right
now actually
betting steph curry to win mvp because
uh
that's really what should happen he
should be the mvp because he is
stop it he should not be the mvp his
team is barely going to make the
playoffs
if they're lucky kelly he's the most
valuable player no he's not
in the number he might be one of the
best players oh he's not most valuable
stop this nonsense grace i'll say no
i'll i'll save this i'll save this
get in the comments tell me what you
think kelly what is your take
look nicola joking is the presumptive
favorite for a reason
he is not only the best player on his
team but if he
can get this nuggets team a push over
the next couple weeks without jamal
murray i think it's gonna solidify it
we've seen him
as high as what seven to one cabbie
maybe he opened 12-1 but pretty much
when we started doing the show he was
around seven to one i think that's when
you bet him then he was five to one and
i said
just i don't like it uh here we are all
the value is gone and guess what now
he's almost minus four dollars
and he is for a reason i i think we have
to just concede pretty much at this
point
we have what cabbie two and a half weeks
left or so
we'll see if he doesn't end up as a five
dollar favorite before it's all said and
done
kelly was early on the the jokic
bandwagon
last year uh like when he was 12 to one
or 15 to one just one season early
but jokic jokic has got he's got 15
triple doubles
he leads his team in the following
categories points
rebounds assists steals blocks uh
effective field goal percentage true
shooting percentage three-point
percentage doesn't leave but he's like
number two i believe like he's leading
the denver nuggets in every category
without jamal murray even with jamal
murray they're fourth in the west
they have an outside chance of passing
the la clippers
but they're fourth in the west yokitch
is the mvp but
i'll say this i took a page on mikey
loch's book
and i just shot i just booked tickets
with
i have a steph futures i have a giannis
a steph
a lebron a kd a joke itch
and uh i have another few cabs are you
even
twins are you even gonna break even
that's what i need to know
barely i'm gonna barely break it monkey
locks got in my head and at the time
the odds kills they were so big like
they were so long like plus a thousand
plus eight hundred bubba and and who
knew there was going to be this much
jockeying
for mvp um consideration this season but
it happened
i have five of them locked in g-money
are you locking in with your guy steph
curry because
we know there was a lillard there was a
kd where are you at now
so it started off with kd that he got
hurt
then i had to choose somebody else
before
i chose dame lillard i said steph curry
but then i mentioned dame lillard last
week i said the same thing i mentioned
steph curry then i said dame miller this
week
after the week that we just saw curry 85
threes in a month
he's plus 1200. i'm rocking with steph
curry let me get into these comments
let me get into these comments see and
they're rocking with me
gabby they yes they're i see a lot of
of curry in the comments i got a lot of
warriors are in the playing game
box underwater cabbie that should not
matter that
that should not that's great that's
great calling it not matter looking to
collect
it's tuesday that's steph that's
actually steph curry he wants the best
one that's steph calling me telling me
that
everybody in the comments should be
voting him for mvp if they want to win
some money
actually uh but but yeah let me give
away some hoodies let me give away some
hoodies
uh i got locks underwater shout out to
you he's rocking with steph curry
uh you you are walking away with a
hoodie matthew
potenza says luca doncic
with a question mark luca doncic
i don't think so i don't i don't think
so shout out to you you're still walking
over hoodie
uh i got one more for you got me one
more
milwaukee 1919 is rocking with you and
kelly
milwaukee 19 is rocking with you and
kelly yeah it's a joker
yes sir okay milwaukee 1919. steph's a
real mvp so i just wanted to be
i just want to make that known steph is
the real mvp steph is not the real mvp
yeah
yeah no greg you know he's one of the
best players in the league he might be
the best player in the league right now
wins
because there's like six other guys hurt
but is great i love steph
but he's not mvp he's the most valuable
player
if he's off the warriors if he's off the
wall if he's off any team
that is if giannis is off the box is he
not does that not make him
jokic is off the nuggets if luca and
porzingis both go tonight and the
warriors blow out the mountains
off the nuggets i still think they're
okay i still think you
i still think jokage is in them is okay
doc in them with joel they might be okay
those two teams still might be playoff
teams jokic doesn't play with another
all-star i know
neither does steph but joking like jamal
murray has never made an all-star team
if joe kitch is off that team
they'd be that team is deep that that
team is doing that team is that team is
deep now cubby they just got
aaron gordon you know added to the mix
aaron gordon he's super deep jazz he's
with the sacramento kings right
bro they have a [ __ ] they have a bench
they have they have
players they have they like come on bro
we're not just talking about
it's not steph curry he's not the real
mvp steph curry compared to joker's
brother come on
see steph curry's not the real mvp okay
anyway let's move on let's move on
uh last week greg ivory was busy
chopping it up with ufc
champion kamara oozman in jacksonville
at ufc 261 congrats
on that big that big knockout to both
kamar usman and ug money for cashing
that ticket so kelly took over
the parlay segment and to quote the
legendary coach frank robinson
close only counts in horseshoes and
grenades let's take a look at the tick
stick a look at last week's five leg
same game parlay ticket
four for five kills that's an amazing
day at the plate
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa what is those odds wait hold on
hold on
i was filling in for you what did you
think my ticket was gonna look like if
they're like hey
pull down you're in the comments you
gotta pretend to be greg for the day i'm
like okay fine i'm gonna put up a great
[Laughter]
i'm very aware i mean very well now
what's going on
what is going on here thank you for
tuning in the show last week because i
said
everything i needed to say on air thank
you
what what is going on what i i asked her
hey girl
i'm upset i asked her if she was gonna
do a kelly
stewart type of ticket or greg ivory
type of ticket she's like i'm going to
do a greg ivory type of ticket oh
she almost she was one one three point
shot away from it she misses one
three-point three-pointer that ticket
hits and that's uh i don't care remember
what the ticket was
i will say the best part about this cash
is you and i did a bad stream on this
game and i
actually bet every single one of these
singly or a single excuse me
and so it was nice to get to make a lot
of money off this
because you're right at eight to one
yeah
craig the the ball let's see you kelly
the ball is back in your court tonight
um this is your home team the golden
state warriors
can you at least get four for five like
kelly or
for the second time this season actually
wait a five like same game probably
bro time out you can't say like kelly
bro that was eight to one i've done that
before no you have not not
anywhere else minus 134 is the one you
hit
we've we've won before like what are you
even keen bro like
you've never worked you can't just say
four out of five like
we got five check marks that was
eight eight come on i mean you guys are
saying that she uh
she she dedicated that one to me shouts
out to you kelly really appreciate it
but i'm upset eight to one wow uh anyway
you have like one win in the column like
the freaking new york jet i got
way more wins than you will ever have
cabbie you're not even a better
i am better i am better i can actually
confirm
and i talk a lot about bets and he's
always like hey what about this what
about that
i'll i'll i'll retract my statement
cabbie you are uh
are you gonna unit shane cabbie is that
what you're getting into right now
what's that what are we doing here what
kind of strand are we doing here greg
no i'm not gonna slander him no he's
going to say he he doesn't he doesn't
better i mean
he's he's a beginning better cell say
that making me
better yeah a casual better yeah and
great
and greg you're the you're a
professional better now did i miss this
no no i'm far from it okay
i will label myself as greg ivory from
richmond california that i like where's
that where's jaguar g the d where's
jaguar g where's that dude
i'm right here baby i'm right i'm right
here man
all right well get it started tonight
the golden state warriors uh dallas
mavericks five legs same game parlay on
fanduel what do you got for us
i got you guys and kelly to answer your
question i'm a fantastic
better that's what kind of better i am
i'm a fantastic better i just
you know i went in let's see if you can
get two wins this year bro
okay you're not in the mix if it's
winning
we already got one we already got one
cabbie goodness
uh winners only we're not in the mix we
just won us april and you have one
guzman we hit that one
should we talk about some nice juice
minus 455 or would you lay with us
yeah we parlayed that we parlayed that
actually if you paid attention we had uh
we have my guy max payne
on the live on winners only wednesday he
told us
about brandon allen that hit thank you
very much
yeah uh here we go we're going to start
this one off quick
draymond green go get 10 points draymond
10 points guys go get 10. come on greg
like minus 800. he hasn't scored he
hasn't scored 10
10 points in like three weeks this is
plus money kelly this plus
this plus money yeah because this guy
doesn't score 10 he has like
55 rebounds and 85 a cent
that's fair four points gabby let me let
me break it down to you this is why
all right draymond he almost had a trip
dubski yesterday
almost after the last game they played
how many points
i believe he scored eight he scored
eight he was right there
he was almost there you know what i mean
so uh guys i think i think he's gonna
come out and make a statement today he's
gonna make a statement gonna go get the
triple dub
go get 10 draymond moving on it's plus
money too kelly i know you like that
plus money
we're gonna go with the first quarter
over we're going to go with the first
quarter over we're going to do something
with the overs here
i'll get there but we're going to do
something with the overnight i expect
nothing less
greg but you to bet overs
i mean that's what a fantastic better
does right kelly
all right here we go let's let's let's
let's let's let's go to the total
of the game and we're going to go over
223
i'm going to go over 223 i'll tell you
guys what we're doing with the overs
let's continue let's continue here we go
steph curry we we talked about him i say
he's go
he should be the mvp uh cabbie thinks
he's gonna go
over his point total today kelly thinks
he's gonna go over i think he's gonna
hit five
threes steph go hit five simple
real simple and we're gonna end it with
this one
fourth quarter over fourth quarter over
we're taking the trifecta with the overs
here
we're going to go first quarter total
game and fourth quarter
we hit all of them i would love to know
that's the truth quarter handicap where
in the world did that come from you just
expecting just a monster fourth quarter
for both teams
what if it's it's a fantastic it's a
fantastic handicap kelly
i just i'm just expecting a good fourth
quarter from both teams in a fantastic
way
and that's and that's that's that's
that's what we're going to do we're
we're going to rock with this let's see
the odds
let's see if this is eight to one ticket
let's see the ticket
plus this one eight to one no uh all
right twelve to one
okay okay that's that's better than some
of your previous efforts
okay the the draymond green ten ten plus
points i think it's
it's either eight or nine games i think
he's just it's just to reach their
cabs and that's okay because draymond
probably should be able to get some good
buckets in the paint against this
mavericks defense
so i'll give him that much i could see
it i just looked on fanduel it is plus
money so congrats to greg he's correct
thank you thank you kelly i took that
into consideration
all right well remember what you learned
here today steph curry has
19 games left in the regular season to
potentially win his third mvp trophy and
jump over embiid and jokic the br
betting stream the community stream is
still on fire you just
search sports betting and tap community
and there you go some of us get our
picks from there so thank you very much
and we have to give our flowers to kelly
stewart this is her fight she is tapping
out of the box i didn't know you guys
are gonna announce it
forever kelly stewart you are an icon
you are
one of the hardest working people we've
ever worked with your information
and your ability to to synthesize all
this data
that you that you crunch into these
little packets has been amazing
you're you're so impressive as a person
and
as a as a better i know you don't like
to say you're a sharp
but among us you're an absolute g and
you've made us
literally thousands of dollars since
knowing you
it's been an absolute pleasure you're
you're one of a kind
and um we're sad that you're leaving
yeah you're talking out of the booth
totally holding it together now cabbie
in one of his famous monologues
now i'm uh now i'm getting a little sad
so we need to catch another winner
tonight
uh hopefully wait we get a little luca
doncic
action greg's calling timeout go ahead
greg let's hear some final slander
cabbie said made us thousands of dollars
do you mean like
lost those thousands of dollars
not kelly you know it's all love hey
what i need the comments to do let's do
this hey comments let's give her her
flowers while we're here can we get
flowers in the comments please lots of
hearts
lots of love lots of flowers can we get
flowers in love
and hearts in the comments please
appreciate you all the hearts
thank you guys it has been an absolute
blast to work with cabbie and greg
on the show i've had some of the most
fun times with all the trash talk all
the bets
and all the really good friendship that
i've been able to uh
acquire with both of you guys so thank
you guys for putting up with me
and my crazy numbers and my antics and
making this a really
enjoyable experience uh you're always a
member of the family
you can't quit us we can't quit you we
just wish you the best in your future
endeavors
so thank you so much everybody watching
uh watching the group chat
alongside the legendary kelly stewart
and the vibeyist
in on the bay greg ivory my name is
cabby richards and we are leaving the
group chat peace
we miss you cows we miss you already
[Music]
[Music]
you